alrighty what's unprotected this guy
right here one my be two pond and that's
it so what does that mean it means the
b7 pond is also unprotected and the
Queen could access that's that pond
right away so I might want to look into
this move for starters or something else
hmm if I do this and this pawn moves
that's very inconvenient to defend this
pond I can't just move it because I'd be
hanging my night that's what I do mmm
uh okay well i'm gonna go with this as a
start and if this pawn is hit i'm going
to follow up with c3 still want to
follow you know controlling center
squares and these fisher random games
controlling the center squares so i
really look into moving one of these for
puns cdef ponds one or two squares i'll
also be looking into making pawn moves
that will accomplish more than just one
thing so by doing this move I'm
supporting the center and allowing this
Bishop to come out now now that's this
is a little bit clever or actually a lot
clever why didn't I consider that
there's a matin one two three ID that I
could have been running with i was i was
so fixated on the Queen may be getting
to this pond when really the nike get
there in three moves and that could be
very uncomfortable ouch oh man do I have
to do this move are no way how about i
play my rook up or my pot up i mean you
not i meant let's go with this it stops
night see for the night could be playing
to a four should I be afraid
um
okay well nite be three
nightby 393 night be three seems good
defends this pond and is a step in the
direction of maybe making life difficult
for black in fact if I could be getting
to a 5 or C 5 how about I get my other
night out let's go defend this pond and
now Knight a5 and c5 is a very very
serious threat because there is no way
to defend the pond and it's threatening
me if Bishop here I could play Knight a5
attack the pond and defend my own pond
so this is something that black is
needing to pay close attention to all
right let's do it defense & Knight takes
b7 width check this is trouble
hmm
well less than three minutes here
there's a lot of time being invested for
black and I don't know what the best
choice is here because well black is
ready to castle if I don't I mean
they're in a position to drop the King
on top of the rook so now there is no
castling I'm up upon this pond is hit
twice but I think my night already did
its job and maybe should just come all
the way back to defend here or is it
better to just move my pawn up I think
moving my pawn up is best because maybe
my night wants to hang out here and
watch over c5 and also maybe my bishop
would want to play to c3 at some point
but doing that right away trucks structs
the rooks view of the sea for pond so
now what what two minutes
I don't know what to it's tough road
ahead it's definitely a very difficult
road ahead here I don't want this square
to be used by my opponent and I think
going one step further makes things very
uncomfortable for this side of the board
this Bishop is kind of locked out of the
game I have control over this square I
think throwing my knight in here right
now since this dr. bishop will not be
around anytime soon to chase my night
away I think doing this is good so let's
get it in and I could be playing c3 if
this Knight wants to play here I could
kick it away so I'm just looking for
moves that are going to constrain my
opponents activity you don't always have
to be throwing haymakers at your
opponent could play a calmer game that
just involves a lot of constraint so I
could have just run run with a
developing Bishop move but I'm taking
into account what might be a potentially
good move for my opponent may be the
knight coming here I want to be able to
kick it away I don't want on my side of
the board so and for good reason my
opponent is not wanting to deal with my
night right here so just fish up here
just defend that night doubled pawns
that's going to be quite all right my
bishop my dark square Bishop will have a
really nice square right here on d4 if
there's this capture follow up bishop
right here and then pawn right here I
could castle in both directions right
now if I drop my king on my rook I'm
castled Queen side I go like this I'm
kingside castle
I think pond push here is good just so I
could get my queen out Bishop here
Bishop here it's kind of stuck there's a
very little working room for the black
piece at this point no no open files
Queen Bishop rook it's kind of it's very
very tough and I could lock up the
position right here with f4 and the
whole the whole King side is basically
just shut down
hmm
let's see Bishop d4 III f4 well I just
want to be assured of something the
kingside lockdown i see that i could be
getting play over here and let's just do
this my queen could see this isn't just
another quick instance of what i was
saying earlier having pawn moves do more
than just one thing defense even though
it was defended by The Rock I missed
that but the Queen could see Bishop here
there's only one way this Bishop would
get out can't break down this pond this
Bishop can't come out in this direction
so it's only right here and if I get a
bishop here this guy is dead to the game
so let's do this and I could actually
push this night around what I'm looking
to do right now is replace my bishop
with this pond if I get a pond right
there then this guy is definitely dead
to the game so let's come back pawn push
and he's dead so he's out of the game
I'm viewing this is a case where they're
just throwing the kitchen sink at me
their kitchen sink and me I could have
also taken that rook but there's just no
time no time any moves are good getting
kitchen sink here okay time issue right
there turned out to be a bit of a
squeeze as soon as that b7 pond fell
let's back up good game let's flip so
easy to fall into that now I was blind
to this night trying to get to be too
maybe black could try to run with the
night here right away actually I guess
it's not working because night a4 I
could just play b3 and if there's a
night check I play King c2 and the night
is officially out of squares so that
wouldn't be a good idea but maybe
if I were to look at this again in a
different way with this arrangement I'm
going to look to see if I could get a
night here how annoying would that be
having to deal with the night getting to
be seven but anyhow where is there an
improvement here yeah this is tough
Black has to take into account the night
be seven move hmm
yeah this is tough here so I mean what
do you do what do you do here let me
back up mmm I wonder if there should be
this move played and then and then
something like c6 so there's some
lateral defense you've been giving the
Beast have upon something has to be done
with be 7 i'm not quite sure what it is
but as soon as I bring my night out to
be 3 and i have this secured enough so
this is where there's a big slip the
bishop moves i think i think computer
evaluate evaluation will be saying that
lack is maybe just beat at this point
dropping of the pond and a black the
black king having to go go on castled so
it's not it's not even there's not a
convenient way to defend here still
imagine that tricky night like what do
you do c6 rook here that just seems
really weird so i think earlier back
maybe keeping this square available for
your pawn to box out my night once it
plays to be three having a pond on b6 or
something maybe this is a good idea
right now or no because then there's
something gets the night pond up in c6
maybe is a good structure we going with
I can't be certain but being aware of
these unprotected ponds just from the
initial position is going to be very
important and I should have been again
viewing it as the night trying to get to
be seven so just that Queen in one shop